[Musik]
wir sind heute hier in gmünd beim
grenzübergang böhm sein wo unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten im einsatz sind
für gesundheits behördliche kontrollen
in ganz niederösterreich sind insgesamt
460 soldatinnen und soldaten und
zivilbedienstete des ressorts im einsatz
im einsatz gegen die korona pandemie ich
möchte an dieser stelle danke sagen ein
ganz großes dankeschön an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten und
zivilbediensteten die so wichtige
großartige arbeit leisten schulter an
schulter und jetzt keine zeit haben
ostern traditionell mit ihren lieben zu
feiern weil es eben im einsatz sind
daher an dieser stelle ein dankeschön
und frohe ostern gesegneten ostern ihnen
und ihren lieben